ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM.
BURNER HORVATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI.
KANSEN CHU COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
DAILY.
DEEP. EIGHT MEN FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ AS GRAY
[inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY.
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RAY IS.
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO.
SMITH.
STONE.
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER.
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
[inaudible]
THE MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND PATTY OSHA BERMAN OCEAN.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
IT CAN BE SAID THAT THE BIRTH OF
OUR COUNTRY WAS A REVOLUTION
FROM TYRANNY.
IT CAN ALSO BE SAID THAT THE
HISTORY OF OUR NATION.
HAS BEEN AN ONGOING STRUGGLE FOR
JUSTICE.
THE STRUGGLES ARE NEVER EASY FOR
THOSE WITH INFLUENCE AND POWER
TO DOMINATE.
DO NOT RELINQUISH TWO ADVANTAGES
EASILY.
BUT THE HUMAN SPIRIT IS
RESILIENT.
AND GIVEN A JUST CAUSE AND
VISIONARY LEADERSHIP.
OUR NATIONAL HISTORY HAS SHOWN
THE HUMAN DECENCY CAM PREVAIL.
IN NINETEEN FIFTY TWO CESAR
CHAVEZ BEGAN PARTICIPATING WITH
THE COMMUNITY SERVICE
ORGANIZATION.
CSO WAS AS GRASSROOTS DOOR TO
DOOR ORGANIZATION FOR SOCIAL
CHANGE.
DURING THE NINETEEN FIFTIES HE
HELPED DEVELOP TWENTY TWO NEW
CSO CHAPTERS IN THE MEXICAN
AMERICAN NEIGHBORHOOD TO SEND US
A IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE CESAR CHAVEZ
BECAME THE NATIONAL EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE COMMUNITY
SERVICE ORGANIZATION.
HIS GOAL FOR THE CSO WAS TO
EVENTUALLY ORGANIZE A UNION FOR
FARMWORKERS.
IN MARCH OF NINETEEN SIXTY TWO
WHEN THE CSO REJECTED HIS
PROPOSAL TO CREATE A UNION FOR
FARMWORKERS.
HE RESPONDED BY RESIGNING FROM
THE ORGANIZATION.
THAT SAME YEAR CESAR CHAVEZ
INDOORS TO WORK TO WOULD BECOME
COLD FOUNDERS OF THE UNITED.
FARM WORKERS UNION.
THE HUMAN SPIRIT IS TRULY
RESILIENT.
AND GIVEN THE JUST BECAUSE IN
THIS SCENARIO LEADERSHIP.
OUR NATIONAL HISTORY HAS SHOWN.
THE HUMAN DECENCY WILL CONTINUE
TO PREVAIL.
NUMBER ONE THE NUMBERS TO WEAR
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER LACKEY.
YEAH PLEASE JOIN ME AS WE PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG AND WHAT
IT STANDS.
FOR READY BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. EIGHT EIGHT
ZERO AND YES.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY MARCH
FOURTEENTH TWENTY NINETEEN
EIGHTIES ONLY MET AT NINE AM ON
WILL KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO
TEM OF THE SOME THE PRESIDING
CHEAPER THE DOCTOR WILSON AT THE
DESK.
READING THE CATALINA LUIS MISTER
CALDERON MOVES.
AND THIS MELENDEZ SECONDS THAT
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE
.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCES FOR THE DAY. FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY WELL OUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FLORA LACKEY IN
GONZALEZ HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY IS GUESTS
WILL BE SEATED AT HIS DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON TO
SPEAK ON AND GERMAN IN MEMORY
TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER PLEASE REMOVE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY TO AB SEVEN
SIXTEEN CHANNEL FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND RE REFER THE BILL
TO THE PRIVACY CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE.
THE BILL WAS INADVERTENTLY
REPORTED TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER THE FOLLOWING BILLS
COMMITTEE.
SB SIX OH TWO BERMAN FROM THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE AB SIX NINETY
SEVENTEEN FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE A. B. TWELVE
EIGHTY SEVEN IS ERIN.
FROM AGING AND LONG TERM CARE
COMMITTEE TO THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK TO THE
AGING AND LONG TERM CARE
COMMITTEE.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO CHAO
FROM THE PRIVACY CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND THEN
BACK TO THE PRIVACY CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
MEMBERS WE HAVE
SPECIAL GAS IN THE CHAMBER TODAY
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE YOUR ATTENTION TO
MISTER FLORA WHO HAS GAS IN THE
CHAMBER WITH US TODAY WHICH
FLORA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING MY
CONSTITUENTS ARE HERE TODAY TO
CELEBRATE THE ASSYRIAN NEW YEAR.
THE PASSAGE OF HOUSE RESOLUTION
TWENTY SIX RECOGNIZING THE
SPECIAL OCCASION.
I'M PLEASE INTRODUCE THE RIVER
THE CHAMBER.
TOMORROW WHILE RAIL FROM THE
BISHOP OF THE CHURCH OF THE EAST
AS WELL AS PRESIDENT HOW HOW
FROM THE SYRIAN UNITED
ORGANIZATION OF CALIFORNIA.
AND IN THE GALLERY OF GREAT
CONSTITUENTS FROM THE STEERING
COMMUNITY SO PLEASE JOIN ME
TODAY WELCOME IN MY CONSTITUENTS
TO THIS GREAT HOUSE
CONGRADULATIONS EVERYONE
.
AND MR LACKEY.
I SEE THAT YOU HAVE A SPECIAL
GUEST WITH US ON THE FLOOR TODAY
MR LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YES
I AM PROUD TO BE JOINED TODAY BY
MY DAUGHTER.
JENNY IT'S J. A AM I NOT JENNY.
NOT JANIE BUT JANNEY SHOW FOR
DENISE AND VERY PROUD TO HAVE
HER JOIN ME SHE'S CURRENTLY AT A
STUDENT AND A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
IN OUR AREA.
VERY PROUD OF HER AND PLEASE
WELCOME WE'RE HERE TODAY
.
AND MISTER MEDINA.
MEMBERS PLEASE KEEP THE VOLUME
LEVEL MANAGEABLE WE HAVE SPECIAL
GUEST WITH US TODAY MISTER
MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE TO INTRODUCE THE
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBERS OF THE
UNIVERSITY COUNCIL AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
WHO ARE UP IN THE GALLERY?
WE HAVE WITH US TODAY MEDIUM THE
GUYVER PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED.
COUNCIL OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS JOHN
RENDON VICE PRESIDENT FOR
LEGISLATION OF YOU SEE A. F. T..
BILL QUIRK.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR YOU SEE A OF
T..
DANIELS.
BOARD MEMBER YOU SEE A OF TEA.
JOY HAGEN BOARD MEMBER YOU SEE A
OF T..
THE UNITED UNIVERSITY COUNCIL
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
IS A UNION OF THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY LIBRARIANS AND MORE THAN
FIVE THOUSAND FACULTY EMPLOYEES.
WHO ARE NOT MEMBERS OF THE
ACADEMIC SENATE OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA?
AND ARE EMPLOYED AT THE TEN
CAMPUSES OF UC.
THE UNIVERSITY COUNCIL IS
AFFILIATED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
AND THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AS WELL AS THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF LABOR.
AND CONGRESS OF INDUSTRIAL
ORGANIZATIONS AFL-CIO AND ITS
LOCAL CENTRAL LABOR COUNCILS
PLEASE HELP ME GIVE A WARM
WELCOME TO THE EXECUTIVE BOARD
MEMBERS OF THE UNIVERSITY
COUNCIL AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS
.
AND MISTER MURATSUCHI MISTER
MURATSUCHI YOU HAVE GUESTS WITH
US YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YES THANK
LEADERSHIP TORRANCE IS IN THE
HOUSE. ONE OF A PROGRAM. FOR US
SPONSORED BY THE POOREST CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE SUPPORTING.
OUR LOCAL LEADERS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING LEADERSHIP TORRANCE.
HEY MISTER PATTERSON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I IT'S A DELIGHT AS THE
CHAIR OF THE AVIATION.
CAUCUS I'M PLEASED TO JOIN WITH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM A TORRANCE IN
OFFICIALLY KICKING OFF THE
TWENTY NINETEEN CALIFORNIA
AEROSPACE AND AVIATION DAYS AT
THE CAPITOL.
TODAY THROUGH WEDNESDAY.
THIS EVENT IS HELD HERE EVERY
YEAR TO INFORM US OUR STAFF THE
PUBLIC ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
THESE INDUSTRIES OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY.
AND TO RAISE AWARENESS OF THE
BENEFITS OF AEROSPACE AND
AVIATION TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
WITH A CONTRIBUTION OF A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
TO OUR STATE.
AND OVER ONE MILLION INDIVIDUALS
EMPLOYED CALIFORNIA'S AVIATION
INDUSTRY CONTINUES TO BE A MAJOR
ECONOMIC LEADER.
WE HAVE WITH US HERE TODAY
MELISSA MCCAFFREY AIRCRAFT
OWNERS AND PILOTS ASSOCIATION
CAROL FOR THE CALIFORNIA PILOTS
ASSOCIATION.
RAY VAUGHN WILLIAMS IS THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
AIRPORTS.
FILLED TURNER NATIONAL BUSINESS
AVIATION ASSOCIATION.
JOHN FIVE FIRST SOUTHWEST
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF AIRPORT
EXECUTIVES AND SCOTT MALTA
PRESIDENT OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AIRPORTS.
WHO ACCEPTED A RESOLUTION IN HOT
IN HONOR OF THIS OCCASION
EARLIER TODAY PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING OUR GUESTS AND PLEASE
JOIN US FOR OUR?
AVIATION -- AND ARE AEROSPACE IF
THAT TODAY TOMORROW AND
WEDNESDAY PLEASE WELCOME OUR
GUESTS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
[inaudible]
SECOND READING.
ASSEMBLY BILL 781-713-7407 WITH
AMENDMENTS TO FIFTY SIX TO
TWELVE WITH THE MEMONS TWELVE AT
THE MOMENT EIGHT FORTY FIVE WITH
THE MOMENT THREE FORTY THREE
WITH THE MOMENT. FOUR OH NINE
WITH THE MOMENT SEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR WITH THE MOMENTS ONE
SEVENTY WITH THE MOMENT AND I
KNOW TO WITH THE MOMENT.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO THE
CONCURRENCE FILE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTEEN ACR THIRTY NINE BY MR
GABRIEL.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY NINE BY FAMILY MEMBER
GABRIEL AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
NATIONAL SPEECH AND DEBATE
EDUCATION DAY.
MR GABRIEL YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ACR THIRTY NINE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE WITH MINOR TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GABRIEL SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE -- CLUB THERE
ALL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU BUT I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN MOVING TO THE
THIRD READING FILE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN AB TWO ONE EIGHT
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
EIGHTEEN BY FAMILY MEMBER
GONZALEZ AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TO CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT.
MS GONZALEZ YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWO
EIGHTEEN WOULD EXTEND THE CIVIL
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
VICTIMS OF CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ASSAULT FROM AGE TWENTY SIX TO
AGE.
FORTY AND IN CASES OF JUST WHAT
DELAYED DISCOVERY FROM THREE
YEARS.
TO FIVE THE BILL WOULD ALSO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF DAMAGES
RECOVERABLE INSTANCES WHERE
THERE WAS A COVER UP WHICH LED
TO FURTHER ABUSE.
ALLOW SHORT THREE YEAR WINDOW
FOR PAST VICTIMS WHO SLIP
THROUGH THE CRACKS TO PURSUE
CLAIMS.
IT'S SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE THAT
BECAUSE SOMEONE IS IN THEIR MID
TWENTIES AND STILL DOESN'T ISN'T
READY TO PURSUE STRESSFUL AND RE
TRAUMATIZING LEGAL RECOURSE WE
TELL THEM THEY'RE OUT OF LACK.
RESEARCH SHOWS IT TAKES DECADES
BEFORE MOST VICTIMS ARE READY TO
COME FORWARD NOT ONLY DOES IS
DENIED JUSTICE TO VICTIMS BUT
ALLOWS THE PERPETRATORS OF ABUSE
AND THOSE COMPLICIT TO CONTINUE
PRAYING ON CHILDREN OR TURN A
BLIND EYE.
WE CAN NEVER RAISE THE PAIN OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT FROM SOMEONE'S
LIFE.
BUT AB TWO EIGHTEEN WE EXPAND
ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR VICTIMS OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT BY
GRANTING THEM MORE TIME TO
PURSUE LEGAL REMEDIES HELPING.
THOSE PERPETRATORS OF SEXUAL
ABUSE AND HOLDING ENTITIES WHICH
WE TRUST WITH OUR CHILDREN IN A
FAILED TO PROTECT THEM
ACCOUNTABLE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ.
MISS MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I'M ABILL
THAT I SUPPORTED IN THE PAST AS
WELL I KNOW THAT FOR REPUBLICANS.
THERE IS AN OPPOSE
RECOMMENDATION BUT I WANT YOU TO
THINK CAREFULLY.
ABOUT THE VICTIMS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE IN THE FACT
THAT WHEN THEIR CHILDREN THEY
DON'T HAVE THE CONFIDENCE. TO
COME FORWARD AND SPEAK ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM I WANT YOU
TO THINK ABOUT YOUR OWN CHILDREN.
WHO OFTENTIMES ARE AFRAID TO
TELL YOU SOME OF THE SIMPLEST
THINGS IN LIFE?
THEY BROKE THIS SURVEYED GOT IN
TROUBLE AT SCHOOL FOR THAT THINK
ABOUT THAT AND PUT THAT IN THE
CONTEXT OF A CHILD WHO NEEDS TO
REPORT SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED
TO THEM IS TO FEARFUL TO DO SO.
WITH THAT I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS MELENDEZ.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM THE CLERK WILL OVER
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
EYES.
FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS.
FOR THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS FIFTEEN THROUGH
EIGHTEEN PASS RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM.
NINETEEN H. R. TWENTY FIVE
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MS GONZALEZ THIS IS
FILE ITEM.
NINETEEN H. R. TWENTY FIVE
COOKERY.
HOUSE RESOLUTION TWENTY FIVE BY
SOME REMEMBER GONZALEZ RELATIVE
TO SAYS THEIR SHOP AS DAY.
GONZALEZ THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER.
AS CHAIR OF THE LATINO CAUCUS I
RISE TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT OF HR
TWENTY FIVE WHICH IT KNOWLEDGE'S
THE LIFE AND LEGACY ASSESSOR
EACH CHAVEZ.
SENSOR CHAVEZ WAS ONE OF THE
GREATEST LABOR LEADERS OF OUR
GENERATION OR MAYBE THE
GENERATION BEFORE OURS FOR SOME
OF US.
CENTER TRAVIS IS WIFE SIR IT'S
AN EXTREMELY SIMPLE HOW ONE
PERSON CAN HAVE SUCH A HUGE
IMPACT ON THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THE WEEKEND --
I LIKE MANY OF YOU ATTENDED A
NUMBER OF EVENTS IN HONOR SAYS
OR CHAVEZ.
AND I ALWAYS ENJOY THESE EVENTS.
BUT SOMETIMES IT SEEMS THAT WE
SANITIZE HISTORY IN A WAY THAT
FITS OUR OWN LIKING.
AND SO WE HEAR ABOUT SAYS ARE
CHAVEZ BEING A GREAT EDUCATIONAL
LEADER A CIVIL RIGHTS ICON.
SOMEBODY WHO CARED ABOUT ANIMALS
IN THE ENVIRONMENT WHILE ALL
THOSE THINGS ARE TRUE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
FIRST IN FOUR MONTHS CENTER
TRAVIS WAS A LABOR LEADER.
HIS ENTIRE GOAL OF ORGANIZING
WAS TO PROTECT WORKERS.
AND NOT JUST ANY WORKERS THE
MOST VULNERABLE WORKERS IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND IN OUR NATION.
WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF DEBATES ON
FARMWORKERS ON THIS FLOOR SINCE
I'VE BEEN HERE.
AND IT'S NOT ALWAYS A PRETTY
HISTORY WE LIKE TO TALK ABOUT.
BECAUSE FARMWORKERS IN FACT DID
COME.
FROM PLANTATIONS IN SLAVERY.
IN EVOLVED INTO A PAID A
PROFESSION ALTHOUGH HISTORICALLY
IN HERE IN THE UNITED STATES
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA.
THEY ARE NOT TREATED EQUALLY.
IN MOST STATES THEY STILL DON'T
HAVE THE RIGHT TO ORGANIZE.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO
MINIMUM WAGE.
BUT HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE
DONE BETTER AND WE'VE DONE
BETTER BECAUSE OF THE WORK
ASSESSOR CHAVEZ IN STARTING THE
UNITED FARM WORKERS IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN SIXTIES.
OF HIS COALITION BUILDING WITH
FILIPINO FARM WORKER LEADERS TO
STRIKE AND DEMANDS MORE IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE TO THE
CREATION OF THE A. R. B. IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE TO THE
DEMAND THAT MINIMUM WAGE APPLY
TO FARMWORKERS IN JUST A FEW
YEARS AGO ON THIS FLOOR.
THE FINAL DEMAND AFTER FORTY
YEARS TO ENSURE THAT FARMWORKERS
FINALLY AND THIS YEAR WE'RE
FINALLY SEEING THE RESULT OF
THIS WELL ACTUALLY GET.
OVER TIME AFTER AN EIGHT HOUR
DAY LIKE EVERY OTHER WORKER.
TODAY I ASK THAT YOU HONOR
THAT'S OUR JOB AS NOT JUST AS
SOMEBODY WHO WHO IS GREAT.
IN THE HISTORY BOOKS BECAUSE HE
SEEMS TO UNDERSTAND THE CROSS
SEXUALITY OF OUR PROGRESSIVE
MOVEMENT.
BUT BECAUSE HE FOUGHT FOR
WORKERS AND WE STILL NEED THAT
KIND OF FIGHT TODAY.
ALTHOUGH NOT ALL WORKERS IN THE
SAME POSITION AS FARMWORKERS WE
HAVE FAR TOO MANY IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT STILL DON'T ENJOY THE SAME
RIGHTS AS YOU AND I THE RIGHT TO
MINIMUM WAGE AND OVERTIME.
THE RIGHT TO FEET PAID FAMILY
LEAVE OR SICK DAYS.
THE RIGHT TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION AND UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE SO THAT FIGHT
CONTINUES TODAY.
AND MY FAVORITE QUOTE MY
FAVORITE QUOTE FROM SAYS HER
CHAVEZ.
IS ONE THAT TALKS ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HONORING
SOMEBODY SOMETHING WE ALL ARE.
WILLING TO DO.
AND DOING SOMETHING.
HE SAID TALK IS CHEAP.
IT'S THE WAY WE ORGANIZE AND USE
OUR LIVES EVERY DAY.
THAT TELLS WHAT WE BELIEVE IN
[inaudible]
WELL.
I BELIEVE IN WORKERS AND SO IT'S
AN HONOR TO STAND TODAY. TO
HIGHLIGHT.
A MAN.
AN ICON.
WHO ALSO BELIEVED IN WORKERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE?
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS.
IN SUPPORT OF HR.
TWENTY FIVE SAYS ARE CHAVEZ WAS
A HUMAN RIGHTS LEADER WHO
BROUGHT DIGNITY TO THE LABOR
FORCE.
ON CALIFORNIA FARMS.
HE EMPOWERED AN ENTIRE
NONVIOLENT MOVEMENT THAT STOOD
FOR EQUALITY AND JUSTICE.
SAYS ARE CHAVEZ WAS ALSO AN
INSPIRATION TO THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY.
AT THE RISE OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ERA.
THE OPPRESSION OF LET YOU KNOW
FARMWORKERS VIOLATED JEWISH LAW.
AND JEWISH VALUES.
FOLLOWING THE WORDS OF THE TORAH
THOU SHALL NOT OPPRESS.
JEWS THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
STOOD BESIDE SAYS A CHAVEZ AND
THE LABOR MOVEMENT.
IN SOLIDARITY ORTHODOX RABBIS
DECLARED THE GRAPES THAT CAME
FROM FARMS OF EXPLOITED LABOR TO
BE -- SHACK OR UNCLEAN.
THIS MORNING I HEARD THE STORY
FROM MARC GROSSMAN WHO WORK WAS
SAYS OUR JOB IS FOR FIVE DOLLARS
A WEEK.
MARC GROSSMAN TELLS THE STORY
THAT SAYS SARS WIFE HELEN WAS
OPENING UP LETTERS.
WITH HER SISTER.
AND AS THEY OPEN THE LETTERS
THEY NOTICED THAT MANY OF THE OF
THE LETTERS WRITTEN WITH THE
CHECKS.
DONATED TO THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS.
THE SISTER SAID ALL HAVE THE
SAME NAME.
RE BE.
HELLO AND HOW TO CORRECT HER
SISTER AND SAY THAT'S NOT RE BE
THAT'S RABBI.
ALL THOSE CHECKS COMING FROM
RABBIS ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
RABBI JOSEPH BLASIER EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE CENTRAL
CONFERENCE OF AMERICAN RABBIS AT
THE TIME SAID THAT AMERICAN JEWS
SHOULD NOT BY TABLE GRAPES.
SO THEY ARE KOSHER.
TELL THE PEOPLE WHO STOOP AND
SQUAT AND GO THROUGH ALL KINDS
OF HELP.
OUT THERE IN THE FIELDS WERE
TREATED RIGHT.
THOSE GRAPES ARE NOT KOSHER.
ACTIVE IS DRIVEN BY JUDAISM'S
TEACHING OF SOCIAL JUSTICE
SOUGHT TO IMPROVE RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC EQUALITY TO MIGRANT
FARM WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA.
I HAD THE HONOR AND THE
PRIVILEGE TO MARCH WAS SAYS A
JARVIS.
BACK IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE I
MARCH FROM THESE VERY STEPS TO
MODESTO. TO TO BOYCOTT GALLO
WINE AT THE TIME.
SO TWO DAYS WE REMEMBER AND
HONOR SAYS OUR JOB IS WE MUST
REMEMBER TO SUPPORT JUSTICE FOR
ALL AND CONDEMN OPPRESSION OF
ANY KIND.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDIA.
MR CHIU KANSEN CHU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FROM YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SOUND --
MEMBERS OF FIRST OF ALL I WON'T
THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR BRINGING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION FOR WORK.
AND ALSO COME GRADUALLY HER
BEING THE DSE SUCH CHAVEZ
NORMALCY FOR A CEASE UP FOR A
DAY.
C. SO PUT IT THE WAR RECEIVE HIM
BY THE CITIES OF JOB AS THE
SCHOLARSHIP FOUNDATION WHICH
WERE HELD.
IN -- SAN JOSE -- LAST FRIDAY.
BY AYE AYE RICE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. TO SUPPORT
H. R. TWENTY FIVE ESTABLISH --
MARCH TWENTY FIRST AT CESAR
CHAVEZ DAY.
IT IS A DAY TO RECOGNIZE AND
HONOR CESAR CHAVEZ TO REMARKABLE
WORK.
IN HELPING THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMITTEE INTO YOUR LIFE TO
STATE.
CESAR CHAVEZ LIKE TO SAY THAT
HIS JOB WAS TO HELP ORDINARY
PEOPLE TO DO EXTRA ORDINARY
THING.
BUT IT WAS HIM WHO WAS ABLE TO
DO THE UNTHINKABLE.
HE CHALLENGE ONE OF THE
COUNTRY'S MOST POWERFUL
INDUSTRIES.
IN CALIFORNIA AND PUSH FOR
CHANGES THAT WILL LOOK AT THE S.
IMPOSSIBLE.
DOING THE FIVE YEAR DELANO GRAPE
STRIKE IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
CHAVEZ LEADERSHIP ABROAD
COMMUNITY FROM ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY. TO SUPPORT OUR FORM
FARMWORKERS IN THEIR STRUGGLE
FOR WORKERS RIGHT INCLUDING
LABOR LABOR UNION CHURCHES
STUDENTS AND CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS.
INFORMING THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS UNION IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX CHAVEZ REACH
ACROSS THE ETHNIC LINE BRING
LATINOS AND FILIPINO WORKERS
TOGETHER.
WORKING WITH FILIPINO AMERICAN
LABOR LEADERS LIKE OF PHILIP
VERA CRUZ.
LARRY A. A LOT IT. EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHTY LEON THANK YOU -- AND
TRAVIS BILL STRONG COALITION AND
OVER AND OVERCOME OBSTACLES SUCH
AS A LANGUAGE BERIA.
AS A COME ON MAN WAS AN UNCOMMON
VISION.
CESAR CHAVEZ THIS.
TWO FOUR THE EQUALITY JUSTICE
AND DIGNITY FOR ALL AMERICANS
HIS VALUE AND BELIEVE REMAIN AS
RELEVANT AND INSPIRING TODAY.
AS THEY WERE WHEN WE FIRST
STARTED THIS MOVEMENT PLEASE
JOIN ME IN SUPPORT OF HR.
TWENTY FIVE AND HONORING THE
LEGACY OF SEE THOUGHT TRAVIS.
THANK YOU MICHELLE.
MR BONTA S..
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FROM THE DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
LGBTQ CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF HR
TWENTY FIVE CELEBRATING THE LIFE
OF SUCH ARE CHAVEZ.
SAYS THERE THOMAS HAS BEEN
A NONVIOLENT NOT THE YOU KNOW
CIVIL RIGHTS ACTIVIST AND A
COALITION BUILDER.
IN ADDITION SAYS ARE CHAVEZ WAS
AN EARLY AND VOCAL ALLY FOR THE
LGBT Q. FOR LGBT Q. EQUALITY HE
SPENT HIS LIFE FIGHTING FOR
DIGNITY FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS AND
UNDERSTOOD.
THAT YOU CAN'T DEMAND EQUALITY
FOR YOUR OWN PEOPLE WHILE
TOLERATING DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST ANYONE ELSE HIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH HARVEY MEL
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST OPENLY GAY
ELECTED OFFICIAL IS A CLEAR
EXAMPLE.
OF HIS WILLINGNESS TO STAND WITH
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY.
THIS ATTEMPT FOR CROSS MOVEMENT --
ORGANISE AYE ORGANIZING FOR BOTH
MEN.
GAVE THE ABILITY TO BRIDGE THE
GAP BETWEEN THE TRADITIONAL
BELIEVES OF RELIGION AND
TOLERANCE AND INCLUSIVITY FOR
ALL.
SAYS ARE TRAVIS LEGACY CONTINUES
TO LIVE IN INSPIRE PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND
THROUGHOUT OUR NATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ONE H. R..
TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU MS ROGERS.
DOCTOR WEBER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I TO
RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF HR
TWENTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE.
BLACK CAUCUS WE'RE HONORED TO
HONOR CESA CHAVEZ ON HIS DAY.
A DAY THAT WE THINK IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT IS AS IMPORTANT AS THE
MLK DAY IN TERMS OF PROVIDING IT
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO WORK HARD TO BRING CHANGE.
WITH KNOWLEDGE ACESSO CHAVEZ FOR
WHAT HE GAVE US WHICH WAS
COURAGE.
COURTESY BEYOND THE CURRENT SUCH
CIRCUMSTANCES AND TO ENVISION A
WORLD THAT DID NOT EXIST AT THE
TIME.
IT TOOK COURAGE TO SACRIFICE HIS
OWN LIFE HIS OWN CAREER. FOR
THOSE WHO STOOD A NEED FOR
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO ARE POOR
AND POWERLESS AND SOME FOLKS
EYES AT TO TREMENDOUS COURAGE.
IT TOOK COURAGE TO LIVE ONE'S
COMMITMENT TO HELP THOSE
INDIVIDUALS TO ACHIEVE WHAT WAS
NECESSARY IN THE FEELS.
AND TO GIVE THEM A LEADER AND A
VOICE THAT WAS UNAFRAID.
AND OBVIOUSLY TOOK COURAGE TO
WALK WITH DELIVERANCE AND SIMPLY
TAKE ACTIONS WERE ACTION WAS
NEEDED.
MY ANGELO SAYS THAT IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO ACTUALLY LIVE OUT
THE VALUES OF YOUR LIFE WITHOUT
COURAGE.
BECAUSE WHATEVER YOU BELIEVE IN
IT WILL TAKE COURAGE TO
IMPLEMENT THAT ON A CONSISTENT
BASIS.
YOU I'M PROUD TO STAND A DAY
BECAUSE I'M PROBABLY ONE OF THE
FEW ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES.
WHO ACTUALLY REMEMBER CESA
CHAVEZ?
REMEMBER THE GREAT STRIKE AND
REMEMBER THE MOVEMENT.
MY ROOMMATE AT THE TIME.
WAS A YOUNG LATINO FROM BUT SOME
SAN BERNADINO.
WHO DID NOT KNOW WHAT SHE WANTED
TO DO WITH HER LIFE BUT SHE WAS
PERSISTENT ABOUT GOING TO SCHOOL?
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN I LOOKED UP
AND IRENE WAS GONE.
SHE HAD GONE TO THE GRADE STRIKE.
SHE'D BEEN A STUDENT FOR TWO
YEARS AT UCLA.
AND THOUGHT IT WAS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT FOR HER TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE TO BASICALLY
CHALLENGE WHAT WAS GOING ON AND
THAT INSPIRED ALL OF US BECAUSE
WE WERE YOU KNOW COMFORTABLE
SOMEWHAT COMFORTABLE POOR
STUDENTS AT UCLA IN THE DORM.
AND KIND OF A DISTANCE FROM THE
GREAT STRIKE.
AND I READ LESS.
IN THE MIDDLE OF HER JUNIOR YEAR.
TO GO INTO WORK IN THE GREAT IN
IN THE FEELS.
IT CHANGED HER LIFE.
AND IT REALLY CHANGED HOURS
BECAUSE WE REALIZE OF IRENE IS
OUT THERE FIGHTING WE COULD NOT
BE SITTING HERE IN WESTWOOD
EATING GRAPES.
WE HAVE TO FIGHT IN WHATEVER
CAPACITY WE CAN'T BECAUSE IT WAS
SO IMPORTANT TO HER.
THAT SHE WAS THERE THAT SHE WAS
INVOLVED AND IT INSPIRED HER
THAT SHE BECAME EVENTUALLY END
UP CAME BACK TO SCHOOL.
GOT A DEGREE WENT TO LAW SCHOOL
AND BECAME EIGHT AN ATTORNEY
WITH THE LATINO MOVEMENTS THAT
WITH THEIR IT BECOMES EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT WE LOOK AT THIS
BECAUSE THIS WAS NOT.
A COMFORTABLE TIME FOR PEOPLE TO
MAKE CHANGE.
PEOPLE MAY TREMENDOUS SACRIFICES
IN THE PERSONAL LIVES AND I'M
SURE THEY WERE PROBABLY GO TO
SAID THIS WON'T MATTER.
THIS WON'T COUNT YOU ARE WASTING
YOUR TIME.
AND YET SHE FOUND IT IMPORTANT
AS WELL AS THOUSANDS OF COLLEGE
STUDENTS TO GET INVOLVED IN TO
TRY TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE THAT
WAS THERE.
I WANT TO CHALLENGE US TODAY AS
WE THINK ABOUT OUR COMFORTABLE
SITUATION THAT WE LIVE IN.
THAT THERE ARE MANY MANY
INDIVIDUALS WHETHER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN OUR STREETS WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT VIOLENCE IN OUR STREETS
WILL EVEN TALKING ABOUT THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN POLICE
OFFICERS IN US.
AND THE USE OF LETHAL FORCE THE
QUESTION BECOMES DO WE HAVE THE
COURAGE TO CHALLENGE THE SYSTEM
THAT EXISTS. TO FIGHT AGAINST
THE SYSTEM THAT PEOPLE HAVE
BECOME VERY COMFORTABLE WITH.
YET HAS RESULTED IN VERY
NEGATIVE AND I THINK ABOUT THAT
ALL THE TIME EVERY TIME WHEN
WE'RE ON THIS FLOOR WE ARE
MAKING IMPORTANT DECISIONS ABOUT
OUR LIVES AND WE CELEBRATE THE
PAST WE'VE CONSTANTLY CELEBRATE
THE PAST.
WITHOUT REALIZING THAT EVERY DAY
WE ARE RIDING THE PAST.
WE'RE WRITING HISTORY FOR THE
DAY THAT WILL BE THE PAST FOR
TOMORROW AND THE QUESTION
BECOMES TO ALL OF US WHAT WILL
OUR CHILDREN SAY ABOUT US WHEN
WE ARE GONE.
WELL THEY TALK ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE AND THE
COURAGE WE HAVE TO FACE THOSE
CHALLENGES DESPITE WHAT WE SAW
EACH AND EVERY DAY.
OR WILL THEY SIMPLY SAY THAT OUR
FAMILIES OUR PEOPLE WERE
COMPLICIT.
THAT WE WERE SILENT ON CRITICAL
ISSUES AND REFUSE TO STAND UP
WHEN WE COULD TO SIMPLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE I REMEMBER I READ
EVERY DAY WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE
GREATEST.
I REMEMBER WHAT SHE DID THAT WAS
SO IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE THOUGHT
WOULD RUIN HER LIFE.
AND YET IT ENHANCED HER LIFE IT
MADE HER THE KIND OF ATTORNEY
THAT SHE BECAME AND THE
COURAGEOUS WOMAN THAT STOOD UP
FOR THOSE WHO COULD NOT STAND
FOR THEMSELVES.
AND IT CHANGED HER CAREER HER
PROFESSION AND HER TRAJECTORY I
THINK THAT IS SO EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AS REMEMBER CESA
CHAVEZ THAT YES HE MADE A
DIFFERENCE IN THIS IN THE
CALIFORNIA IN THE NATION.
BUT HE ALSO MADE A DIFFERENCE IN
OTHER PEOPLE'S LIVES WHO TODAY
CONTINUE TO CARRY FORWARD THE
MESSAGE THAT HE HAS ABOUT
JUSTICE AND EQUALITY AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS FOR US TO STAND
UP FOR THOSE WHO CAN'T STAND FOR
THEMSELVES.
AND TO BE UNAFRAID AND
COURAGEOUS AS WE TALK ABOUT
CHANGE SO IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO HONOR HIM BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO LIVE UP THE
EXPECTATIONS THAT WE HAVE FOR
EACH AND EVERYONE OF US.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I
BOTH THE H. R..
TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION.
ON THE RESOLUTION MS GONZALEZ
YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH AND
WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
I WOULD LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION I'LL JUST AND AGAIN
AND I THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO FOR BRINGING IT HOME.
AT AGAIN THE WORDS OF SAID THE
TRAVIS AND SELF TALK IS CHEAP.
SO ALTHOUGH I WANT YOU TO CO
AUTHOR THIS RESOLUTION OF COURSE
I WANT TO VOTE FOR THIS
RESOLUTION IT'S WHAT YOU DO
AFTER THAT THAT MATTERS IT'S HOW
WE LIVE HIS LEGACY IN A WAY THAT
MATTERS FOR OUR OWN CONSTITUENTS.
FOR OUR OWN COMMUNITIES AND
CONTINUE WORKING IN THE FACE.
OF OPPOSITION AND CONTINUE BEING
BRAVE SO OF COURSE I ASSET WE WE
OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS I
ASK YOU VOTE THAT WAY AND I ASK
THAT YOU JUST CONTINUE TO ACT
WITH COURAGE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ AND WITH
THAT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CO AUTHORS ON HR.
TWENTY FIVE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CULTURAL THERE ARE SIXTY FOUR CO
AUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
THERE WAS THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
TWENTY APOLOGIES MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE DOCTOR
EGGMAN.
DR ED WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR ME TO ASK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
I RISE TO YOU TODAY AND THEY'LL
BE.
WALKING IN SHORTLY I BELIEVE --
TO INTRODUCE TO YOU MONEY OUT TO
CHAVEZ IN AWARD WINNING MARIACHI
FROM SUCH A TRAVIS HIGH SCHOOL
IN STOCKTON.
DESERT CHAVEZ HIGH SCHOOL IS THE
MOST RECENT ADDITION TO A
STOCKTON UNIFIED HIGH SCHOOLS
AND WILL WE NAMED OUR MOST
RECENT HIGH SCHOOL WE TOOK GREAT
PRIDE AND HONOR IN NAMING IT
AFTER SIX OR CHAVEZ WHO.
AS PEOPLE KNOW THE LORD'S WORK
DOES FROM STOCKTON.
ITALY í
AN ORGANIZED AROUND THE SHORT
HANDLED HOE -- AND WE CONTINUE
THAT PRIDE OF THAT MOVEMENT IN
TWO THOUSAND FIVE YOU KNOW THE
AMOUNT THIS NO RELATION THAT WE
KNOW OF THEN A FRESHMAN.
SUGGESTED -- TO THEN DIRECTOR
MAY ALSO GET THàNH -- OF OUR
FILIPINO COMMUNITY THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE A MONEY ARCHIE --
PLAYING THEY ARE AWARD WINNING
THEY HAVE TRAVELED ACROSS THE
NATION -- AND YOU CAN SEE IN THE
FACES THE BEAUTIFUL DIVERSITY
THAT IS CALIFORNIA THAT IS
STOCKTON AND IF THEY TRAVIS DID
SO MUCH FOR US IN THE LABOR
MOVEMENT WE KNOW THAT HE ALSO
USE THEATER.
AND MUSIC AS A WAY TO BRING
PEOPLE TOGETHER TO FEEL THE JOY
AND SO IT IS OUR PRIDE TODAY.
THE PRIDE OF STOCKTON TO PRESENT
FOR YOU MIGHT HAVE TO CHAVEZ
[inaudible]
YEAH
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS WE ARE BACK ON
THE FILE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY AB
TWELVE EIGHTY NINE BY DR CHAN
THE CLERK READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWELVE EIGHTY NINE
BY SOMETHING NUMBER TEN AND
ACTUALLY PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS. THIRTY CHEN YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PRESENTING A. B. WELL THE NINE
WHICH WILL SPECIFY THAT IS NOT
THE ALARM COMPANIES LEGAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
THE TEAM LOCAL USE PERMITS FOR
THE CUSTOMERS THIS BILL RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THEY GET A CHANCE SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
THE CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY FIVE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
WHILE I WAS TWENTY ONE OF TWENTY
TO PASS RETAIN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY THREE H. R. EIGHTEEN BY
MISTER KALRA CORKERY.
HOUSE RESOLUTION EIGHTEEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER KALRA AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE SAKE.
MISTER KALRA YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS HOUSE RESOLUTION
EIGHTEEN RECOGNIZES THIS YEAR'S
MY SAKE IT WAS CELEBRATION ON
SUNDAY APRIL FOURTEENTH.
AND ENCOURAGES CALIFORNIA'S TO
TAKE PART IN CELEBRATIONS IN
THEIR COMMUNITY.
THIS YEAR'S MY PSYCHE IS
PARTICULARLY SPECIAL FOR THE
SICK COMMUNITY BECAUSE IT IS THE
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY OF BIRTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE FIRST AND
POUNDING SPIRITUAL MASTER GURU
NANAK.
AN ANCIENT POSSIBLE GREAT
SIGNIFICANCE TO SIX TWO SIX
HINDUISM BUT THIS IN MANY
REGIONS OF INDIA AND OTHER PARTS
OF SOUTH AND SOUTHEAST ASIA.
BY SAKE IS CELEBRATED ANNUALLY
ON APRIL THIRTEENTH OR
FOURTEENTH BY CALIFORNIANS WITH
SICK.
AND INDIAN HERITAGE. FOUR SIX BY
SAKE HOLD SPECIAL RELIGIOUS AND
HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE BECAUSE
IT COMMEMORATES THE CREATION OF
CALLS -- AND INITIATED THE FIVE
CASE TRADITION OF THE CALLS ARE
THAT CONTINUES TO BE THE BASIS
FOR THE UNIQUE SICK IDENTITY.
WHERE BY SIX WHERE CASH ON GET
HERE CONGA A WOODEN COMB CUT OFF
AN IRON OR STEEL BRACELET ONE ON
THE WRIST GET UPON AN ARTICLE OF
FAITH TAKING THE FORM OF A SWORD?
AND CATCH IT A SHORT REACHES.
I THINK IT'S ALSO APPROPRIATE AS
WE HONOR CESAR CHAVEZ TODAY THAT
WE CELEBRATE BY SAKE WHICH IS
CELEBRATED BY THE SICK AMERICAN.
COMMUNITY.
ARE SICK AMERICAN BROTHERS AND
SISTERS REALLY ARE THE
FOUNDATION OF THE SOUTH ASIAN
COMMUNITY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
COMING HERE TO WORK AS LABORERS
ASKED FARMWORKERS.
WITH LATINO AND FILIPINO
BROTHERS AND SISTERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA FARMS AND THE SIX
AMERICAN COMMUNITY POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA IS ONLY THE LARGEST
BUT STILL RESIDES HEAVILY IN OUR
FARMING.
COMMUNITIES.
AND SO I I ASK ALL OF YOU TO
JOIN IN CELEBRATING BY SAKE.
AND H. AND H. R. EIGHTEEN
SPECIFICALLY WHICH EXPRESSES
CALIFORNIA'S DEEP RESPECT FOR
ALL WHO OBSERVE AND CELEBRATE BY
SAKE IN THIS STATE.
AND THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOAT AN
ASSET THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA MS WICKS
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES AND RECOGNIZING THE
SAKE AND CELEBRATE OUR SEEK
AMERICAN COMMUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN THE EAST BAY.
BUT SAKE IS A GREAT CULTURAL AND
RELIGIOUS SIGNIFICANCE TO SIX
AROUND THE WORLD.
THE SAKE IS BOTH A TRADITIONAL
HARVEST FESTIVAL IN INDIA AS
WELL AS THE DATE ON WHICH SEEKS
COMMEMORATE.
AND CELEBRATE THE CULMINATION OF
A CENTURIES LONG JOURNEY TO
FORMALIZE SICK IDENTITY AND
SHARED VALUES.
AND IDENTITY WHICH IS FOUNDED ON
THE PRINCIPLES OF EQUALITY
FREEDOM OF RELIGION AND
COMMUNITY.
I HAD THE HONOR OF REPRESENTING
REPRESENTING A VIBRANT SICK
AMERICAN COMMUNITY MY DISTRICT
IS HOME TO A SIZABLE SICK
AMERICAN POPULATION.
AND IS HOME TO THE FIRST COULD
WALROND.
OR SICK HOUSE OF WORSHIP THAT
WAS ESTABLISHED IN THE BAY AREA.
THE GOOD LAURA OF ELSA BRONTE.
AND IT IS STRIKING IN ITS
ARCHITECTURAL BEAUTY IT'S AT THE
TOP THE EAST BAY HILLS
OVERLOOKING THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY.
AND IT'S DISTINCT GOLDEN DOOM
STANDS OUT FROM THROUGHOUT THE
VALLEY BELOW.
IT IS A FITTING MONUMENT TO SEEK
VALUES.
I RECENTLY HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
JOINING THE CONGREGATION OR SON
GOT.
OF THE ELSA BRONTE GOOD LARA FOR
THEIR SERVICES AND I WAS STRUCK
BY HOW THIS COMMUNITY IS TRULY
GENEROUS AND WELCOMING TO ALL.
THESE VALUES ARE FUNDAMENTAL TO
THE SIKH FAITH AND IDENTITY.
AND IT IS EXEMPLIFIED BEST BY
THE SEEK PRACTICE OF THE LONGER
LONGER IS THE PUNJABI TERM FOR
FREE KITCHEN WHERE ANYONE CAN
JOIN THE COLLECTIVE MEAL EVEN
WHILE SITTING ON THE FLOOR.
THESE MEALS ARE OFFERED TO ANY
VISITOR WHO WANTS TO JOIN FREE
OF COST SEEK OR NON SICK ALIKE.
THERE IS A LONGER PRESIDENT ALL
SEEK TEMPLES TO EMPHASIZE AND
APPALLED THE PRINCIPLES OF
EQUALITY AMONG ALL PEOPLE
REGARDLESS OF RELIGION CAST
COLOR CREED AGE GENDER OR SOCIAL
STATUS.
THIS AND DURING AND RESILIENT
COMMITMENT TO A QUALITY AND
UNIVERSAL GENEROSITY IS
PARTICULARLY MOVING WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THE ADVERSITY MEMBERS
OF THE SIKH FAITH HAVE FACED
THROUGHOUT HISTORY.
AND MORE RECENTLY HERE IN
AMERICA.
OUR SEEK BROTHERS AND SISTERS
KNOW ALL TOO WELL WHAT IT'S LIKE
TO FACE RELIGIOUS INTOLERANCE.
AND YET THEIR RESPONSE TO SUCH
INTOLERANCE IS TO CONTINUE TO
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF A
QUALITY.
WE MUST FOLLOW THEIR EXAMPLE WE
MUST CONTINUE TO PURSUE A WORLD
OF A QUALITY WHERE NO ONE HAS TO
FACE PREJUDICE AND INJUSTICE
BECAUSE OF THEIR RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS.
AND WE'RE EVERYONE FEEL SAFE IN
THEIR PLACE OF WORSHIP.
SIKH AMERICANS OUR OUR NEIGHBORS.
THEY ARE OUR FRIENDS THEY ARE
OUR FAMILY.
THERE ARE FUNDAMENTAL PART OF
THE AMERICAN FABRIC OF LIFE.
SEEK VALUES ARE INDEED AMERICAN
VALUES HUMAN VALUES VALUES WE
CAN ALL LEARN FROM.
COLLEAGUES I ASKED TO JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING.
THE SAKE AND THE AND THE SEEK
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND I WISH
ALL OF MY SEEK AMERICAN FRIENDS
A HAPPY AND HEALTHY THE SAKE.
THANK YOU MS WICKS MISTER COOPER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M PROBABLY CO AUTHOR HR
EIGHTEEN WHICH RECOGNIZES THE
SAKE.
THE SAKE IS THIS THE NEW YEAR AS
WELL AS THE SPRING HARVEST
FESTIVAL.
THIS YEAR THE SAKE WILL BE HELD
ON SUNDAY APRIL FOURTEENTH.
DRIVEN SAKE THE ENTIRE CITY
COMMUNITY COMES TOGETHER FOR
VARIOUS COMMUNITY CELEBRATIONS
INCLUDING PARADES WORSHIP
DANCING.
COMMITTEE SERVICE THE RAISING OF
THE SIKH RELIGIOUS FLAG MY
DISTRICT IS HOME TO A LARGE THE
COMMUNITY NAPA SUPPORT AN URGENT
AYE VOTE.
ON HR.
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS COOPER MISTER TO
KANSEN CHU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SAM
MEMBERS I RUSHED IN SUPPORT OF
HR.
THIRTEEN IN THINK MY COLLEAGUES
FROM SAN JOSE FOR BRINGING THIS
TO THE FLOOR AND ALSO HOSTING.
THE TURBAN DATE.
A TWO YEARS IN A ROW.
LET'S TALK HE IS A SPECIAL DAY
FOR MANY OF MY CONSTITUENTS WAS
RELIGIOUS AND CULTURES SIX
SIGNIFICANCE.
I WANT TO WISH -- TO CELEBRATING
BUT SAKE THE JOY FOR M. REMEMBER
MY MEMORABLE TIME I ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE. TO PARTICIPATE IN YOUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY EVENT TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT ANOTHER CULTURE AND
YOUR PRACTICES.
ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO A
WONDERFUL TRADITION CELEBRATION
IN MY DISTRICT I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH TOO MUCH
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IS A CO AUTHOR OF HR.
EIGHTEEN I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FOR TODAY.
AS A PROUD REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
OF A VERY LARGE SEE COMMUNITY.
I IN THE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
I CAN TELL YOU VERY MUCH THAT --
THIS IS A COMMUNITY THAT.
YOU KNOW HAS COME TO THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT HAS MANY OF THEM WORK IN
THE FIELDS AS WE SPOKE OF THIS
MORNING.
AND HAVE BUILT A LIFE FOR
THEMSELVES OF BUILT A LEGACY
THAT IS VERY MUCH THE AMERICAN
DREAM -- AS WE SAID AS WE
CELEBRATE WITH THEM WITH A SAKE --
TODAY AND AND MANY OF THEIR
TRADITIONS.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S AWESOME TO
SEE THAT AS THIS THIS THIS
FABRIC OF AMERICA THAT WE ALL
HAVE BEEN AS WE AS WE TODAY
LEARN ABOUT THE TURBINE AND AND
LEARN ABOUT ALL THE DIFFERENT
FACETS OF OF THAT FAITH.
THE VERY MUCH AS A IS ABOUT
GIVING ABOUT GIVING AND AND
LOVING YOUR MANKIND -- AND THOSE
AROUND YOU IN YOUR COMMUNITY --
I HAVE IN MY DISTRICT IN YUBA
CITY WE HOST -- THE SEEK PARADE
WERE EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
CONVERGE UPON -- YUBA CITY WHICH
IS I WOULD SAY IT'S A SMALL CITY
BUT IS GROWING SO MUCH NOW THAT
MAYBE I CAN'T SAY THAT AS MUCH
ANYMORE -- BUT CONVERGE UPON --
THAT CITY AND I CAN TELL YOU AS
YOU WALK TO THE OPERATORS ARE
HANDED.
THIS GIVEN FOOD AND DRINK.
AND AS PEOPLE CELEBRATE TOGETHER --
YOU YOU YOU TRULY SEE YOU KNOW
WHAT THIS COMMUNITY IS ALL ABOUT
AND I KNOW THAT THE C.
COMMUNITIES NOT THE ONLY ONE
THAT CELEBRATES -- THIS DAY BUT
YOU KNOW AS WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO I GUESS YOU KNOW GIVE GIVE
SOME EDUCATION -- TO SHARE
SOMETHING ABOUT THE FAITH -- TO
GIVE TO BRING ABOUT GREATER
AWARENESS AND UNDERSTANDING.
OF THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE WHO ARE.
VERY MUCH A PART OF OUR STATE
OUR COUNTRY OUR NATION -- MEN
HAVE MADE IT -- EVEN EVEN BETTER --
SO WITH THAT I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AND I WOULD ASK THAT YOU.
PLEASE SUPPORT HR EIGHTEEN THANK
YOU.
JAMES GALLAGHER MISTER PATTERSON.
I GOT MY RISE VERY QUICKLY --
AGAIN AS I DID -- LAST TIME WE
HAD DETERMINING OPPORTUNITY YOU
LOOK REALLY COOL AND IT ALL
RIGHT.
I HAD THE JOY.
OF BEING TURBAN THAT TWO YEARS
AGO -- AND TO LEARN THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF IT WHICH WAS
REALLY REALLY NICE -- I ALSO
HAVE KEPT THE TURBINE IT IS IN
MY OFFICE -- AND WE BRING IT OUT
EVERY NOW AND THEN.
I CAN'T.
CLAIM TO KNOW EXACTLY HOW TO GET
IT.
PUT BACK ON BUT EVERY NOW AND
THEN IF YOU VISIT ME I'M IN MY
OFFICE -- YOU MIGHT SEE THAT
TURBAN.
RESTING ON MY BUST OF RONALD
REAGAN.
LOOKS KIND OF COOL.
THANK YOU I I SUPPORT THIS WE
HAVE A WONDERFUL SEE COMMUNITY
AND IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA FRESNO
A SUCCESSFUL GENEROUS -- AND WE
PREACH THEM APPRECIATE THEM VERY
VERY MUCH AND I URGE A AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THERE IS PATTERSON MITHRAS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I ALSO RISE.
AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON HR
EIGHTEEN I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
JOINING MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ASH KALRA TO THE VISIT IN
INDIA -- IT WAS WONDERFUL TO BE
ABLE TO INTRODUCE HIM TO SO MANY
OF THE PEOPLE WE VISITED WITH.
TO INTRODUCE HIM AS THE FIRST
INDIAN AMERICAN TO EVER SERVE IN
THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
A WHILE WE WERE IN THE GOLDEN
TEMPLE WE ALSO WENT TO THE SICK.
WE VISIT WITH THE SICK -- AND
FOUND OUT THAT ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE [inaudible]
ARE SERVED [inaudible]
EVERY DAY. ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
SO IT DOESN'T MATTER WHERE
YOU'RE COMING FROM IF YOU COME
YOU WILL BE SERVED.
AND THEN IT IS IT'S BEEN AN
HONOR FOR US TO HELP WITH THE
CLEANING OF THE DISHES -- OR THE
TRAYS AND THE ENTIRE PROCESS WAS
WAS QUITE -- QUITE A BLESSING
FOR THE REST OF US WHO DID JOIN
MY COLLEAGUE FIVE RISE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF HR EIGHTEEN THANK YOU.
THEY ADDRESS THANK YOU MEMBERS
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THIS CALL REMAIN CLOSE WE WISH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I JUST
WANT TO THANK ALL MY COLLEAGUES
WHO.
SPOKE AND WHO HAVE SUPPORTED
THIS RESOLUTION BOTH THIS YEAR
IN YEARS PAST UP M<c.cyan> FOR YOUR</c>
KNOWLEDGE IN YOUR UNDERSTANDING
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO LEARN ABOUT.
OUR SICK AMERICAN COMMUNITY -- A
BETWEEN INTRODUCTION THE MOMENT
BUT I JUST WANT TO AGAIN MAKE
MENTION OF THE WILL BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERYONE TO
DONNA BEAUTIFUL TURBANED LATER
THISAFTERNOON SO I LOOK FORWARD
AND HOPEFULLY HAVE TO HAVE YOU
ALL THEIR AND THEY ALSO JUST ONE
LAST THING I WANT TO SAY -- THE
FIVE COLLEAGUES THAT DID JOIN ME --
OUR TRIP TO INDIA TROUBLING TO
PUNJAB I THINK THAT -- THE ONCE
YOU GET FROM THE PET JOBBIK MANY
FROM THE SIX AMERICAN COMMUNITY
IS UNLIKE ANY OTHER.
AND YOU'LL FEEL THAT WHEN YOU GO
INTO YOUR OWN COMMUNITY
EVERYBODY HERE HAS A GOOD WATER
EITHER IN THEIR DISTRICT OR
NEARBY SO PLEASE TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT.
AND GET TO KNOW YOUR LOCAL SICK
AMERICAN COMMUNITY BUT THAT I
RESPECT THE ASTRONAUT ABOUT MASS
FOR THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN TO
QALAT THERE'S YOUR SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA MEMBERS
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION CARP
LOCAL.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ADDING TO HR.
EIGHTEEN THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY TWO
CO AUTHORS ADDED WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND MISTER KALRA BACK
TO YOU FOR YOUR SPECIAL GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
I JUST WANT TO ASK TO ARE THOSE
THAT ARE HERE FROM THE SICK
AMERICAN FEW TO STAND THERE SOME
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S
ANY.
ALSO ON THE BACK OF THE GALLERY
BUT I JUST LIKE TO TELL WELCOME
SOME GREAT LEADERS FROM AROUND
THE STATE.
AND IN PARTICULAR I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE JOYOUS SAME A SLOGAN
SAGE COMMUNITY THANK ON CAR
BRIDGES AND THE SAN JOSE GOOD
WATER WHICH IS THE LARGEST IN
THE WESTERN HEMISPHERE WHICH IS
IN MY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. FOR CO
HOSTING THIS AFTERNOON'S TURBINE
DAY AT THE CAPITOL -- AND SO I
WISH EVERYONE CAN COME TO MEET
OUR COMMUNITY LEADERS AND MANY
MORE THAT WILL BE AT THE
RECEPTION AT THREE O'CLOCK IN
ROOM.
THREE SEVENTEEN AND I ALSO WANT
TO GET A SPECIAL HAPPY BIRTHDAY
WILL WISH TO HER BE ABOUT YEAH.
SO THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE MORE ITEM ON
FILE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR H.
R..
TWENTY SEVEN BY MISTER BERMAN.
THE CLERK READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION TWENTY SEVEN BY
SEVEN NUMBER BERMAN RELATIVE TO
THE TWENTY TWENTY DECENNIAL
CENSUS.
MR BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES.
TODAY WE ARE ONLY ONE YEAR OUT
FROM SENT TO STAY.
TWENTY TWENTY AND HR TWENTY
SEVEN RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE
OF ENSURING A COMPLETE AND
ACCURATE COUNT IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS.
BEGINNING A YEAR FROM NOW THE
UNITED STATES CENSUS BUREAU WILL
BEGIN THE ONCE A DECADE PROCESS
OF COUNTING EVERY PERSON IN THE
COUNTRY.
IT IS NOT HYPERBOLE TO SAY THAT
THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS WILL
SHAPE CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE FOR
DECADES.
IT WILL AFFECT FUNDING AND
POLICY DECISIONS THAT IMPACT
EACH AND EVERYONE OF THE
COMMUNITIES WE REPRESENT.
CENSUS DATA IS USED TO DETERMINE
THE NUMBER OF SEATS EACH STATE
HAS IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
AND IT IS TEN TO DISTRIBUTE
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN FEDERAL FUNDING.
UNDER ACCOUNT COULD THREATEN AT
LEAST ONE OF CALIFORNIA SEATS IN
THE U. S. HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
AND SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE OUR
STATE SHARE OF FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
EDUCATION.
HEALTHCARE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
OTHER VITAL SERVICES.
WITH MUCH TO LOSE IT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT EVERY
RESIDENT IN CALIFORNIA IS
COUNTED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS.
ACCORDINGLY OUR STATE IS MADE AN
UNPRECEDENTED INVESTMENT IN
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH AND WE'RE
ORGANIZING EARLIER THAN EVER
BEFORE.
WITH BETTER COORDINATION.
BUT FOR ALL OF OUR EFFORTS THE
CHALLENGES TO A COMPLETE COUNTER
GREATER THAN EVER BEFORE.
THE STAKES ARE TOO HIGH AND
THERE ARE NO DO OVERS.
WITH THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
DAYS AGO I AM GRATEFUL FOR ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS WHO
ARE ACTIVELY ENGAGING THE MOST
VULNERABLE AND HARD TO COUNT --
POPULATIONS WHOSE PARTICIPATION
IS CRITICAL TO OUR SUCCESS IN
SECURING A COMPLETE AND ACCURATE
COUNT OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
BUT EACH OF US HAS A ROLE TO
PLAY.
WE ARE ALSO TRUSTED MESSENGERS
AND WE NEED TO GET WORD OUT
ABOUT THE CENSUS AND WHY
PARTICIPATION IS SO IMPORTANT.
THERE WILL BE MANY OPPORTUNITIES
FOR EACH OF US TO ENGAGE IN THE
COMING YEAR AND I ENCOURAGE ALL
OF YOU TO DO SO.
YOU CAN START TODAY BY JOINING
ME IN SUPPORTING HR TWENTY SEVEN
AS WE KICK OFF THE YEAR LEADING
INTO THE CENSUS.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN MS
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LATINO LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS TO SUPPORT HR.
TWENTY SEVEN AND ITS MESSAGE OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE DICE ENELE
CENSUS.
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS IS
IMPORTANT TO EVERY PERSON IN OUR
STATE BUT OUR EFFORTS TO REACH A
COMPLETE COUNT ARE ESPECIALLY
CRITICAL FOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WHERE THERE IS A HISTORY
OF UNTER CAM UNDER COUNTING
CALIFORNIANS.
BOTH CITIZENS AND UNDOCUMENTED.
CALIFORNIA'S POOR PERFORMANCE IN
THE NINETEEN NINETY CENSUS
RESULTED IN AN UNDERCOUNT OF
SOME EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND PERSONS.
COSTING OUR STATE BILLIONS IN
FEDERAL FUNDS OVER THE OVER THE
SUCCEEDING TEN YEARS AND A VERY
MALE MAY HAVE EVEN COST US A
SEAT IN CONGRESS.
SOME STONE EFFORTS IN
200-020-0010 CENSUS PROVED OUR
ACCOUNTS.
IMPROVED OUR ACCOUNTS BUT STILL
RESULT IN UNDER COUNTING INCOMES
CONSIDERATE.
COMMISERATE SKEWS ME LOTS OF
FEDERAL RESOURCES.
THE TWENTY TWENTY SINCE THIS
WILL BE QUICKLY UPON THIS AND I
AM PROUD TO SERVE WITH CHAIRMAN
BERMAN ON THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE CENSUS.
CREATED AFTER GOVERNOR BROWN
ISSUED HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER
ESTABLISHING THE CALIFORNIA
COMPLETE COUNT IT COMMITTEE LAST
APRIL.
IT'S OUR STATE EARLIEST EFFORT
TODAY.
THROUGH SCHOOL BASED OUT REACH
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND EXPANDED
MULTI LINGUAL MULTI MEDIA
CAMPAIGN.
IT IS MY GREAT HOPE THAT WE WILL
COUNT EVERY PERSON IN CALIFORNIA.
TO PROTECT OUR FIFTY THREE SEATS
IN THE U. S. CONGRESS HAVE
ACCURATE REPRESENTATION IN STATE
AND CONGRESSIONAL LIKE IT'S
LEGISLATIVE DISTRICTS.
AND RECEIVE A FAIR SHARE
RESOURCES FROM FEDERAL SPENDING
PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN FOR
RECOGNIZING THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
OUR SENSES EFFORT THROUGH HR
TWENTY SEVEN AND FOR YOUR
PERSONAL COMMITMENT. TO OUR
SUCCESSFUL CENSUS COUNT
COLLEAGUES I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MR MCCARTY YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
ON BEHALF OF OUR LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF HR.
TWENTY SEVEN A COMPLETE CENSUS
COUNT IN CALIFORNIA AS WAS
STATED MORE INDIVIDUALS ARE
CONCERNED HARD TO COUNT THESE
INCLUDE FOREIGN BORN RESIDENTS
RENTERS PEOPLE LIVING CLOSE TO
ARE AT THE POVERTY LINE.
IN CHILDREN YOUNGER IN THE AGE
OF FIVE THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AND COMMITTEES OF
COLOR HAVE LONG BEEN UNDER
COUNTED IN PRIOR.
A CENSUS THIS IS WHY WE A
COMPLETE ACCURATE COUNT OF OUR
OF OUR STATE'S POPULATION AND
ACCURATE COUNT NOT ONLY
DETERMINES THE APPROPRIATE
NUMBER OF CONGRESSIONAL SEATS
BUT HOW MUCH MONEY CALIFORNIA
RECEIVES.
FOR EDUCATION PROGRAMS HEALTH
CARE PROGRAMS -- PROGRAMS THAT
MONITOR DISCRIMINATION IMPLEMENT
CIVIL RIGHTS AND REMEMBER FEWER
FEDERAL DOLLARS.
AS OF AS OF OUR IMPROPER CENSUS
MEANS MORE PRESSURE ON OUR STATE
GENERAL FUND.
H. R. TWENTY SEVEN RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS AND SUPPORTS HELPING TO
ENSURE A COMPLETE FAIR AND
ACCURATE COUNT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY MR CHOW
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ON BEHALF OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF HR
TWENTY SEVEN RELATIVE TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS.
PARTICIPATING IN A TWENTY TWENTY
SENSES IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
OUR DIVERSE API COMMUNITIES
VISIBLE AND ALSO ENSURES THAT
OUR COMMUNITIES WILL BE
REPRESENTED.
TO AND THAT WE AS POLICY MAKERS
HAVE THE DATA NECESSARY TO MAKE
THE RIGHT DECISIONS FOR ALL
CONSTITUENTS.
FROM THE TWENTY TEN CENSUS WE
LEARNED THAT -- ASIAN AMERICANS
WHO ARE THE FASTEST GROWING
RACIAL GROUP IN THE COUNTRY.
WHAT CALIFORNIA HAVING THE
SECOND HIGHEST ASIAN AMERICAN
POPULATION? FIVE POINT SIX
MILLION PEOPLE AN INCREASE OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION FROM THE TOWARD THOUSAND
SENSES.
WITH A NUMEROUS CHALLENGES
FACING OUR COMMUNITIES WHERE
TWENTY TWENTY CENTS SAYS SUCH AS
THE UNTESTED CITIZENSHIP
QUESTION LIMITED LANGUAGE
ACCESSIBILITY AND ALSO THE NEW
ELECTRONIC FORMAT.
IT IS IMPORTANT NOW MORE THAN
EVER TO INCREASE AWARENESS OF
THE SENSES AND ALSO TO ENSURE
THAT THERE ARE ENOUGH RESOURCES.
TO REACH OUR HARD TO COUNT
POPULATIONS WITHOUT IRISH ARE
YOU AYE VOTE ON HR.
TWENTY SEVEN THERE WAS CHAU.
MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT HR -- TWENTY
SEVEN AND ONE THING THAT YOU
KNOW A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS
pHAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP BUT ONE OF
THE BIG ISSUES IS.
THE DISASTERS THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY THE ONE THAT
JUST OCCURRED IN MY DISTRICT
WHERE MANY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
DISPERSED.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THE CENSUS
THAT WE ENSURE PEOPLE ARE
COUNTED -- PEOPLE THAT A DESIRE
TO RETURN TO THEIR HOMES THAT
DESIRE TO COME BACK TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES THAT WE GET THAT
RIGHT -- THEY MAY BE IN OTHER
LOCATIONS NOW -- BECAUSE OF
THESE DEVASTATING.
EVENTS THAT HAVE OCCURRED UP AND
DOWN THE STATE -- BUT CERTAINLY
CALIFORNIA IS THEIR HOME --
THESE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED OUR THEIR HOME AND WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT -- THAT THE
IN THE CENSUS THAT -- THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE COUNTED -- AND
THAT THE RESOURCES ARE BROUGHT
TO THOSE MUCH NEEDED RESOURCES
ARE BROUGHT TO THOSE AREAS AS
WELL.
SO WITH THAT I I REGION I HAVE A
THANK YOU MISS GALLAGHER THANK
YOU MEMBERS SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION ON THE RESOLUTION.
MR BERMAN YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES WHO SPOKE
OF TODAY I ONE THING MY
COLLEAGUES WERE SERVING ON THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE CENSUS
WE HAD.
BETTER PARTICIPATION OTHER
HEARING A COUPLE WEEKS AGO THAT
I'VE EVER SEEN FOR ANY SELECT
COMMITTEE -- AND WANT TO THANK
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO OF PUT
US IN TOUCH WITH THEIR DISTRICT
STAFF TO MAKE SURE THAT.
MY STAFF IS REACHING OUT TO YOUR
STAFF WITH INFORMATION SO YOU
CAN MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IN RESIDENTS GET
COUNTED.
THERE REALLY IS NO BETTER RETURN
ON INVESTMENT IN MAKING SURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
COUNTED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
DAVIS BERMAN WITHOUT THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THERE ARE SEVENTY CO
AUTHORS ADDED TO IT WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY DAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION.
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS REMOVING THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
IS A MEMBER WHICH REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND
EXAM CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
ACTUALLY TWO ATTORNEYS AND THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL EYES SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
AND THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
NINE NINE ONE I SEVENTY THREE
THERE WAS.
ZERO IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED OF GERMANS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS A QUORUM CALL IS NOT
LIFTED THE QUORUM CALL IS NOT.
LIFTED MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS FOR GERMAN TO MEMORY.
AND GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES.
OR MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
.
MISTER PATTERSON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
UP.
I ASK THAT YOU A GERMAN IN
MEMORY.
FOR CAPTAIN JACK YANDELL.
HE WAS A BELOVED FIGURE IN
SHAVER LAKE.
UP IN THE THE FOOTHILLS OF THE
SIERRA -- IN MY DISTRICT HIS
FRIENDS CALLED HIM THE KING OF
KOKANEE SALMON -- HE
UNOFFICIALLY WAS SUPPORT WAS
APPOINTED THE MAYOR OF SHAVER
LAKE.
JACK'S PASSION FOR HELPING
PEOPLE TO CATCH FISH MADE MANY
TRIPS TO THIS WONDERFUL LATE.
US VERY SPECIAL FOR THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES.
ACT CAPTAIN JACK WAS A IS
BELOVED NICKNAME HE WAS
EVERYBODY'S FRIEND INCLUDING
MINE.
JACK MOVED TO SHAVER LAKE AFTER
RETIRING IN NINETEEN NINETY AS A
MANAGER AT ROCKETDYNE.
ROCKET ENGINE DESIGN AND
PRODUCTION COMPANY.
THERE HE MADE AEROSPACE ENGINES
USED IN NASA'S APOLLO SPACE
PROGRAM.
AFTER RETIRING JACK MOVED TO
SHAVER HE OPENED CAPTAIN JACK'S
TACKLE BOX TO HELP SHARE THE
JOYS OF FISHING WITH OTHERS
INCLUDING.
MYSELF MY BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
MY CHILDREN AND NOW MY GRAND
CHILDREN.
HE WAS THE FIRST OFFICIAL
FISHING GUIDE AND MADE A HUGE
IMPACT ON THAT COMMUNITY.
HE IS UP.
CREDITED WITH STARTING A KOKANEE
FISHING REVOLUTION IN -- SHAVER
LAKE AND FOR MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES -- FROM PLACES OTHER
THAN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA I'M SURE
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH SHAVER LAKE
THE HUNTINGTON LAKE AREA AS
LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS -- COME TO THAT
BEAUTIFUL PART OF CALIFORNIA AND
MANY OF YOU PROBABLY ENJOYED
CAPTAIN JACK -- BUT YOU DIDN'T
KNOW WHO HE WAS AND WHY ALL
THOSE YELLOW HATS WITH THE BIG
FISHING CREEK WAS ON THEM.
THAT WAS CAPTAIN JACK'S HACKED
AND HE HAD SO MANY OF THOSE IN
CIRCULATION I KNOW I HAVE ONE AT
HOME.
I WEAR MINE -- IN HONOR OF HIS
MEMORY AND HE WAS KIND ENOUGH --
TO SIGNED AN AUTOGRAPH IT FOR ME
HE WAS. EIGHTY FOUR YEARS OLD HE
WAS SURROUNDEDBY HIS DAUGHTERS
WHO LOVED HIM DEARLY HE WAS
PRECEDED IN DEATH BY HIS BELOVED
WIFE JOANNE.
WE MESS CAPTAIN JACK BUT WE
WON'T MISS THE JOY OF KNOWING
HIM.
AND THE JOY HE GAVE US IN
KOKANEE FISHING AT SHAVER LIKE
THANK YOU FOR JOINING IN HIS
BELOVED MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISS PATTERSON THANK
YOU MEMBERS.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SESSION SCHEDULE WAS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY APRIL SECOND CHECK IN
SESSION.
WEDNESDAY APRIL THIRD CHECK IN
THURSDAY APRIL FOURTH FLOOR
SESSION IS AT NINE AM ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASS AND
RETAIN.
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED
SEEING AND HEARING -- FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS.
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY APRIL FOURTH AT
NINE AM IN A QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED
.
MORE CHANGE SIXTY EIGHT THE
DISTRICTS STEVEN CHOI -- FOR AB
TWO EIGHTEEN FROM OPPOSED TO NOT
MORNING.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTEEN NO TO
NOT VOTING